bonjour merci d'être en direct avec mon
sur rt france expliqué auquel
d'instruction avez vous reçu de la part
du ministère ou bien du rectorat
alors pour l'instant écouter on a reçu
un mail sur notre boîte professionnelle
hier à 18h54 nous expliquant
effectivement que la campagne de tests
salivaires allait démarrer dans les
dents dans les écoles de zones à qui ont
repris cette semaine mais on n'a
absolument pas d'informations
supplémentaires
donc on est encore une fois comme vous
le dites dans le flou et la préparation
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas ou peu
d'infos et on sait pas du tout comment
comment ça va se passer
mais pour l'instant après pas
d'obligation à réaliser ces tests
alors pour l'instant oui pas
d'obligation de toute façon il ya ce
geste aussi simple qu'il a l'air d'être
dans ce que vous montrez dans leur petit
le petit reportage vidéo vous montrer
juste juste avant vous fait
effectivement on demanda les enfants de
déposer un petit peu de salive dans un
dans un dans un petit un petit tube un
petit pot ça reste comme un geste
médical donc la raison pour laquelle
l'inquiétude qu'on peut avoir
parce que effectivement on pourrait
demander à des enseignants d'être
présent ou alors de faire d'avoir à
l'accomplir ce geste vous demandez aux
enfants de le faire c'est que le
problème de fond c'est le sait là c'est
la place de la médecine est la place des
infirmières et des infirmiers scolaires
dans les établissements
on n'a pas une maîtrise vous demandez
exactement qu'est ce qui vous dérange
dans cette démarche
mais la raison pour laquelle on demande
à des enseignants mon métier d'enseignés
d'éduquer les élèves de faire ce type
d'avoir ce type de geste c'est
simplement parce qu'il n'y a pas les
moyens humains pour pour les faire
auprès des élèves
simplement c'est ça il n'y a pas de
médecine du travail dans l'éducation
nationale
dans l'académie de lille il ya deux
médecins de prévention pour 45000
enseignants je ne veux pas le jeep à
l'ombre des lèvres il n'y a pas
suffisamment d'infirmiers et
d'infirmières scolaires on est en train
de territorialiser leurs activités c'est
à dire qui ne dépendront plus du
ministère l'éducation nationale mais de
collectivités locales et voilà donc on
n'a pas d'information et dans l'urgence
et ben on a l'impression que l'éducation
nationale on va demander
enseignants ils peuvent tout faire quand
on a pas de faux en gros vous estimez
que vous n'êtes vous n'avez pas à
réaliser ces tests salivaires c'est ça
on n'a pas les réaliser parce que tout
simplement on a absolument aucune
formation pour savoir comment comment ça
c'est ce qu'on va faire
et puis encore une fois on est
absolument aucune aucune information sur
sur le sens de ce l'est il faut aussi
savoir qu'il ya quelques mois on a on a
mis en place une campagne de tests pour
les enseignants premier second degré
mais aussi pour les élèves de lycées et
de collèges donc pas encore
effectivement donc là pas de possibilité
de le faire pour les les élèves en
primaire mais c'est simplement parce
qu'il n'ya pas de moyens qui sont mis
suffisamment dans l'est dans les
établissements pour une vraie campagne
de tests donc là on est en train
d'improviser quelque chose on n'a pas
d'informations je vous dirais la seule
information que j'ai eu en tant
qu'enseignant c'est un mail à 18h54 hier
soir sur ma boîte professionnelle voilà
c'est pas satisfaisant du tout en
quelques mots à quoi ressemble
aujourd'hui la gestion de la crise
sanitaire au sein des établissements
scolaires le respect des
gestes-barrières c'est toujours très
compliqué où finalement les choses ont
pris finalement les toutous les élèves
et les enseignants ont pris leurs
marques et les choses et bien suivre
leurs cours à peu près normalement
alors les enseignants et les élèves ont
pris leurs marques effectivement ce qui
pose problème c'est l'évolution des
protocoles ces trois dernières semaines
il a il a bougé trois fois ce protocole
sanitaire et puis on va lire honnêtement
les choses on peut pas l'appliquer ce
protocole nous ce qu'on demande c'est
que l'éducation nationale fournisse des
gestes pendant des des masques
chirurgicaux pour les élèves qui doivent
emporter à partir de 6 ans c'est pas le
cas donc et les enfants qui y portent le
même masse toute la journée qu'ils
portent parfois même masse plusieurs
jours d'affilée
sinon qui n'ont pas des masques adaptés
à leur taille ou tout simplement qu'ils
respectent pas les normes qui sont fixés
on demande la possibilité de d'aérer
correctement les salles c'est pas
toujours le cas dans ma classe moi j'ai
vingt-huit élèves
j'ai quelques jets 4e à l'e3 quatre
fenêtres qui s'ouvrent en aussi en
battant c'est pas satisfaisant du tout
pour aérer donc web dans ma classe je
peux pas faire l'aération qu'avec le bon
donc il faut réfléchir à la façon dont
on peut à eric correctement pour éviter
la diffusion du virus
j'enseigne à bayonne moi je suis à 100
quand km de dunkerque donc on sent la
pression et l'inquiétude chez les
collègues
et puis évidemment bien sûr pour
appliquer les gestes barrières ont plus
de l'aération il faut que l'éducation
nationale nous fournissent de quoi fin
du gel hydroalcoolique pour que les
élèves puissent se laver les mains c'est
pas le cas là on voit sur la vidéo en
même temps on voit qu'il gèle drôle
cliquer sur toutes les tables ce n'est
pas le cas l'éducation nationale ne
fournit pas de gel hydro alcoolique dans
les écoles les mairies éventuellement et
papa l'éducation nationale et puis bien
sûr évidemment je pense qu'il faut
envisager pour le personnel enseignant
une campagne de vaccination voilà
maintenant on en est là on est plus au
test no show de la vaccination
merci pour votre témoignage à linthal e
instituteur co secrétaire du syndicat
snuipp fsu nord